GO RIGHT TO HIS LEGAL TEAM, SEE
WHERE THEY STAND.
JOINING ME NOW IS CHRISTINA
BOBB, ATTORNEY FOR PRESIDENT
TRUMP, WHO WAS ON SITE FOR THAT
RAID.
CHRISTINA, THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US TONIGHT.
DOES PRESIDENT TRUMP SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THE RELEASE OF THE
AFFIDAVIT?
>> WELL, PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
BEEN VERY STRAIGHTFORWARD IN
THAT HE SUPPORTS ALL
TRANSPARENCY THROUGH THIS
PROCESS, AND HE WANTS WHAT'S
BEST FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND
HE'S GOING TO RELY ON THE COURTS
TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
>> Laura: SO HE WILL NOT THEN
SUBMIT OR YOU WILL NOT SUBMIT A
MOTION TO THE COURT TO RELEASE
THE AFFIDAVIT IN OPPOSITION TO
WHAT THE GOVERNMENT SAID TODAY.
>> WE SUPPORT WHAT JUDICIAL
WATCH HAS STARTED.
WE'RE WATCHING IT VERY CLOSELY
TRYING TO GAUGE WHAT'S HAPPENING
AND WILL RESPOND ACCORDINGLY.
I DON'T HAVE AN EXACT ANSWER
TODAY.
WE'RE WATCHING THE SITUATION AND
SEEING HOW IT DEVELOPMENTS AND
WE'LL RESPOND IN A WAY THAT WE
THINK IS BEST FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Laura: SO NO DETERMINATION ON
THAT AS OF NOW.
BECAUSE THAT IS THE MOST CRUCIAL
PIECE OF INFORMATION, BECAUSE
THAT DOCUMENT --
>> YEAH.
>> Laura: -- APPARENTLY
ESTABLISHES, THEY SAY, PROBABLE
CAUSE.
IT INCLUDES SENSITIVE
INFORMATION.
THE GOVERNMENT'S ARGUING.
THEY DON'T WANT TO COMPROMISE, I
GUESS, COOPERATING WITNESSES.
AND SO FAR IT'S THEIR CASE
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP SUCH
THAT IT IS.
>> RIGHT.
YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT AND
SUPPOSEDLY IT DOES HAVE PROBABLE
CAUSE IN IT.
I FIND THAT A LITTLE BIT HARD TO
BELIEVE.
OBVIOUSLY A JUDGE SIGNED IT.
BUT KNOWING THE BACKGROUND AND
THE SITUATION, I DON'T THINK
THERE IS PROBABLE CAUSE TO DO
WHAT THEY DID.
SO I AM MYSELF CURIOUS TO SEE
WHAT'S IN IT, AND WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO SEEING HOW THIS ALL
PLAYS OUT.
>> Laura: BUT YOU'RE NOT -- I
MEAN, I DON'T KNOW, GIVEN THE
PRESIDENT'S COMMENTS EARLIER, WE
WOULD THINK THAT HE WOULD WANT
IT ALL OUT, OUT THERE SO
EVERYONE CAN SEE IT IN THE LIGHT
OF DAY.
I'M STILL NOT FOLLOWING WHAT
WOULD THE CONCERN BE ON YOUR
PART FOR NOT HAVING IT RELEASED?
>> NO, WE ARE SUPPORTING IT.
WE'RE NOT -- I'M NOT AWARE OF
ANY EFFORT TO OPPOSE IT.
WE JUST ARE FOLLOWING THE LEAD
OF THE CASE THAT'S ALREADY GOING
AND WATCHING TO SEE WHAT HAPPENS
IN RESPONSE TO IT.
>> Laura: OKAY, FAIR ENOUGH.
>> HE ABSOLUTELY -- YEAH.
>> Laura: SO HE'S NOT OPPOSING
ITS RELEASE, BUT HE'S NOT GOING
TO URGE THAT IT BE RELEASED, IS
THAT A CORRECT CHARACTERIZATION?
>> I WOULD SAY THAT'S A FAIR
ASSESSMENT AT THIS POINT, YES.
>> Laura: OKAY.
ON THE ISSUE OF THE PASSPORT
WHICH, TO ME, IS JUST ANOTHER
RIDICULOUS WRINKLE HERE.
EARLIER TODAY THE PRESIDENT SAID
THAT THE FBI STOLE HIS THREE
PASSPORTS, ONE EXPIRED, AN
ASSAULT ON A POLITICAL OPPONENT
NEVER BEFORE SEEN IN OUR COUNTRY
AND APPARENTLY TOLD OUR
PROSECUTORS JUST BEFORE THE SHOW
THAT THE PASSPORTS HAVE NOW BEEN
PICKED UP, SO YOU GOT THEM BACK,
TWO EXPIRED, ONE'S THE
DIPLOMATIC PASSPORT THAT EVERY
PRESIDENT GETS TO KEEP IN HIS
POSSESSION.
WHAT'S YOUR VIEW ON THIS?
THIS WAS JUST AN HONEST MISTAKE?
WERE THEY IN A DRAWER?
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT ANY
HONEST -- I WON'T GIVE THEM THAT
MUCH CREDIT AT THIS POINT.
I THINK THIS GOES TO SHOW THE
LEVEL OF AUDACITY THAT THEY
HAVE.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO EXECUTE A
RAID ON THE PRIMARY RESIDENCE OF
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES, YOU NEED TO DO IT
PERFECTLY.
THERE'S NO ROOM FOR ERROR.
AND WHEN OUR FOURTH AMENDMENT
RIGHTS ARE AT STEAK AS A NATION
YOU CANNOT BE FLIP ANT IN ANY
WAY.
SO I DON'T GIVE THEM A PASS AS A
SIMPLE MISTAKE.
I THINK IT GOES TO SHOW HOW
AGGRESSIVE THEY WERE, HOW
OVERREACHING THEY WERE, THAT
THEY WERE WILLING TO GO PAST THE
FOUR CORNERS OF THE WARRANT AND
TAKE WHATEVER THEY FELT WAS
APPROPRIATE OR THEY FELT THAT
THEY COULD TAKE.
AND THEN GO BACK THROUGH AND
LOOK THROUGH EVERYTHING ONCE
THEY REALIZED, OH, WHOOPS, MAYBE
WE WENT A LITTLE TOO FAR THEN
NEGOTIATE THE RETURN OF IT.
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY NOT THE WAY A
WARRANT IS SUPPOSED TO BE
EXECUTED.
SO, NO, I THINK THEY WERE WRONG
AND BASICALLY GOT CAUGHT.
>> Laura: WHERE WERE THE
PASSPORTS?
WERE THEY IN A SAFE?
WERE THEY IN A DRAWER, A BOX?
I MEAN, WHERE WERE THEY?
>> I DON'T ACTUALLY KNOW.
THEY WERE PROBABLY IN THE
OFFICE, I WOULD ASSUME, BECAUSE
THAT MAKES THE MOST SENSE.
BUT, AGAIN, THEY DIDN'T DISCLOSE
WHERE THEY PICKED THINGS UP SO I
CAN'T SAY FOR CERTAIN.
>> Laura: NOW, IN HIS FIRST
INTERVIEW SINCE THE RAID, THE
PRESIDENT TOLD FOX NEWS DIGITAL
THAT PEOPLE ARE SO ANGRY AT WHAT
HAS TAKEN PLACE, WHATEVER WE CAN
DO TO HELP, THE TEMPERATURE HAS
TO BE BROUGHT DOWN IN THE
COUNTRY.
IF IT ISN'T, TERRIBLE THINGS ARE
GOING TO HAPPEN.
WHAT DID THE PRESIDENT MEAN BY
TERRIBLE THINGS ARE GOING TO
HAPPEN?
>> I THINK HE JUST IS LOOKING AT
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE COUNTRY
AND REALIZING THE ANGST PEOPLE
ARE GOING THROUGH.
I THINK HE'S SADDENED BY THE
FRUSTRATION THAT AMERICANS ARE
FACING AND REALIZING THAT THEIR
GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN HIJACKED BY
RADICALS, RADICALS THAT DON'T
CARE ABOUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND DON'T CARE ABOUT OUR QUALITY
OF LIFE AND OUR CULTURE.
AS A CULTURE, THIS IS A NEW STEP
THAT WE'VE NEVER EXPERIENCED
BEFORE AND A LEVEL, TO SOME
EXTENT, OF FEAR IN THE NATION
THAT THE GOVERNMENT'S BECOMING
OVERREACHING.
AND I THINK HE'S CONCERNED ABOUT
THE DEVO SOLUTION OF OUR
CULTURE.
I DIDN'T ASK THE QUESTION BUT
THAT WOULD BE MY SPECULATION
THAT HE DOESN'T LIKE THE
DIRECTION IT'S GOING.
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT'S
INTIMATING PEOPLE COULD COMMIT
VIOLENCE, ANOTHER JANUARY 6TH.
BUT YOU'RE SAYING THAT'S NOT
WHAT YOU BELIEVE.
>> NOT AT ALL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP -- CORRECT.
NOT AT ALL.
PRESIDENT TRUMP LOVES THIS
COUNTRY AND HE'S NEVER SUPPORTED
VIOLENCE.
ALTHOUGH THE LEFT HAS.
SO I THINK IT'S A BIT
HYPOCRITICAL AND IRONIC THAT
THEY WOULD TRY TO THROW THAT
NARRATIVE OUT WHEN HE HAS BEEN
PEACEFUL AND BROUGHT PEACE TO
THE WORLD AND PEACE TO THIS
NATION.
AND IS TRYING TO BRING PEACE TO
THIS NATION.
HE REACHED OUT TO MERRICK
GARLAND AND SAID, YOU KNOW,
ANYTHING I CAN DO, AFTER YOU RA
RAIDED MY PERSONAL RESIDENCE,
SORRY, THIS IS THROUGH HIS
ATTORNEYS BUT HE WANTED A
SPECIFIC MESSAGE TO MERRICK
GARLAND, NOT THEM DIRECTLY
SAYING I WANT MERRICK GARLAND TO
KNOW THAT I SUPPORT BRINGING
THIS NATION TOGETHER AND
LOWERING THE TEMPERATURE, AS
YOU'VE SAID.
WHAT CAN I DO?
YOU KNOW, MY RESOURCES ARE AT
YOUR GOESAL I'M WILLING TO DO
ANYTHING AND THE DOJ IGNORED IT.
THEY DIDN'T RESPOND.
THAT WAS ON THURSDAY MORNING AND
THEN A FEW HOURS LATER MERRICK
GARLAND GAVE A THREE-MINUTE
PRESS BRIEF WHERE HE DIDN'T EVEN
BOTHER TO DISCLOSE TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP WAS TRYING TO BE HELPFUL
IN THIS SITUATION.
SO --
>> Laura:.
>> Laura: WHAT SPECIFICALLY WAS
PRESIDENT TRUMP SUGGESTING?
I MEAN EVERYONE WANTS TO BRING
THE TEMPERATURE DOWN, I THINK
THAT'S A NOTICEABLE DESIRE, OF
COURSE, BUT WHAT SPECIFICALLY
DOES HE PROPOSE THAT HE CAN DO
AT THIS POINT?
>> SURE.
WELL, I THINK HE WAS LOOKING AT
IT SAYING, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DON'T TRUST THE FBI OR DOJ, THEY
LIED ABOUT RUSSIA RUSSIA RUSSIA,
THEY LLOYD ABOUT CROSS FIRE
HURRICANE, THEY LINED TO
CONGRESS, McCABE LIED TO
EVERYBODY, THEY LIED TO THE FISA
COURT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE RIGHTFULLY
DON'T TRUST THE FBI RIGHT NOW
AND DON'T TRUST THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE BUT THEY DO TRUST
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AND HE HAS A BIG PLATFORM.
HE HAS A BIG FOLLOWING.
SO I THINK IT WAS A GENUINE
OLIVE BRANCH TO SAY I'M TRYING
TO HELP THIS COUNTRY.
THEY DON'T TRUST YOU BUT THEY
TRUST ME, WHAT CAN WE DO?
AND THEY IGNORED IT.
>> Laura: SHORT OF DROPPING THE
CASE, I'M NOT SURE WHAT MERRICK
GARLAND WOULD DO AT THIS POINT.
I MEAN, RIGHT?
LET'S MOVE ON.
I MEAN, I DON'T KNOW WHAT ABOUT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT'S GOING
TO DO.
THEY'RE NOT IN FAVOR OF
RELEASING THE AFFIDAVIT.
>> RIGHT.
I THINK IT WOULD GO A LONG WAY
TO SHOW THEY CARE THAT THEY ARE
PUTTING THIS NATION THROUGH
ANGST.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
FRUSTRATED AND ANGRY, THEY LOVE
DONALD TRUMP AND NO ONE BELIEVES
THAT THIS IS A REAL CASE.
THEY BELIEVE IT'S A WITCH HUNT.
SO ANY ATTEMPT TO COME TOGETHER
IS